talk about this thanks russell i'm
really happy to be here again
i was here last fall it was really
exciting
so today what i'm gonna do is i'm going
to just
tell you a little bit about what i've
been doing and what the community has
been doing on
hardness for easy problems whatever that
is i'll explain this in
in a little while and it's not going to
be a technical talk it's just going to
be an introduction to the topic
and i'll go into details in the other
talks of
of this boot camp later on okay
so all right so what are we talking
about
uh how can easy problems be hard so
so let's start with a little cartoon
okay so this is the real world and we're
let's discuss hard problems so we have a
scientist here
and a scientist has done a lot of work
uh they've collected a lot of data
and they say okay i've got all my data
now i need to
analyze it and let's learn something
about it
and i have some algorithmic problem in
mind and i really want to solve it but
i'm stuck and i'm not sure what to do i
haven't found any good algorithms
so then the scientist goes and finds a
computer scientist
okay this is the best cartoon i could
find online i think this is how the
world sees us apparently
okay so yeah the computer scientist
looks at the problem and says well
okay i'm sorry to say this is an np-hard
problem
if you would resolve it in all instances
with a very fast algorithm then you
would solve a very very hard math
problem
computer science and math and so the
scientist says oh
okay everything i tried didn't work but
there's a reason why
i feel better i'm just going to use i'm
going to use my heuristics and i'll be
okay
sometimes they work sometimes they they
won't but
probably the best algorithm has this
problem too
okay so fine so this is some
solution to the heart problems
now the scientist has a different
problem now which they present to the
computer scientists and the computer
scientist says
great news your problem is in polynomial
time i have a quadratic time algorithm
for it
okay so this is wonderful news from our
perspective
but then the scientist says but now you
know i have this huge data and n is
actually enormous so what what should i
do
n squared maybe for small n is really
nice
but my n is actually really huge can't
you find me a linear time algorithm
though i'll be
have much happier with a linear time
algorithm and then the scientist says
i don't know i tried to find a linear
time algorithm
but i couldn't and why aren't you happy
with n squared n squared is perfectly
fine
but but uh yeah
i don't have a good answer for you and
then the scientist says well
should i wait for you to find a linear
time algorithm can't you give me some
reasons why why you don't have one i
mean
isn't that your job okay
and so yeah so what do we do here we
want to have a similar answer
just with the hard problems as with the
easy problems and
yeah so this is what we're kind of
trying to do here
okay so let's have a little aside about
things we all know
uh polynomial time for us can mean
efficient or easy
but that's not because we think all
polynomials are nice
it's because of other technical reasons
because when you compose two polynomial
time algorithms you got to put
you get a polynomial time algorithm you
can also have model independence and
things like this
but of course n to the 100 is
not considered efficient and even n
squared can also be
suboptimal for some applications so
so how do we explain when we're stuck on
improving on problems they have some
n squared or n cube type solution but
for some reason we can't improve it
so usually this solution is something
simple sometimes it just follows from
the definition
and yet getting something better seems
to require some very different
techniques
okay so in this talk i'll talk about
easy problems and by easy hero mean
and square time where n is the size of
the input
what do we know about n squared time
problems
we have really really fast algorithms
for a lot of
interesting problems faster than n
square time
we have all these classical linear time
algorithms
for you know strongly connected
components
spanning tree a lot of problems on
graphs and also
other things like sorting and so on
but also we have really sophisticated
algorithms
that seem to give us really really nice
techniques
to solve more difficult looking problems
like max flow matching
and cost flow and so on
and we also have this area of sublinear
algorithms property testing and so on
and sometimes
we can solve problems really really
really fast
so we have developed a lot of these
techniques
and this is really really great news
uh okay a lot of problems are in close
to linear time a lot of problems we know
we really want to solve and practice we
can actually
we can actually solve now there's also
the bad news
we have a lot of problems that
have some simple algorithm that's
probably the first algorithm that people
came up with when
when they defined the problem and
usually it's a meant to the c
time algorithm okay but then after this
algorithm there was no improvements for
many decades maybe very tiny
improvements like logarithmic
and so here i'll give you a few very
interesting examples of such
problems so
here's a problem in computational
geometry you're given
endpoints in the plane and i want to
know
if any three of them lie on the line so
in other words are these points in
general position
and whenever you want to solve a
computational geometry problem
you want you probably want to first do
this okay
and there is an n squared time algorithm
to solve this problem
for example for every pair of points you
could compute the slope and the
intersect
and then every line is defined by these
two quantities
and you just have to find whether
there's a collision so whether the two
lines
defined by two uh by two pairs of points
you know i
have the same line so you can do this
now this has been known for a long time
uh and oh yes so n squared is known but
no
better than no significantly better than
square so known end to the 1.999
algorithm is known
for this this problem okay so this is
computational geometry
uh and there's many other problems in
the area that have this
issue so
there's also these string matching
problems uh
things like edit distance or sequence
alignment
and longest common subsequence and so on
so usually what you're given is two
sequences and you want to know how
similar they are
so yeah uh let's say you're given two
dna strings and
you just want to know what what is the
similarity and then there's like
there's many many different notions of
similarity
so as i mentioned there's
long the longest common subsequence
which are defined formally on the next
slide but we
teach it in our algorithms courses
there's a slightly more
sophisticated notion called edit
distance there's local alignment
there's uh other
for shade distance and so on you can
define a lot of different notions of
sequence alignment and they're all
solved in practice so in order to figure
out
how how close these sequences are and
the
these problems also have uh applications
to things like spell checking
and computing the difference of two
texts and so on
so here's the most uh the simplest
version of the problem
you're given two strings over some
finite now alphabet let's say the
alphabet of length four
and you want to find a subsequence of
both the strings
that's of maximum length so a
subsequence
can skip letters but it has to be in the
same order as the letter
as in as the sequence itself
so here the blue i can put gaps because
i'm skipping this letter
g and the blue letters form the longest
common subsequence of
of these two sequences and
of course as i mentioned it has a lot of
applications
it also um has an n squared time
algorithm
it's a dynamic programming algorithm
this is the example that i teach in my
algorithms course
and it's also very practically motivated
solve the daily on huge strings now
uh i looked this up it's typically not
solved on the
whole human genome but let's let's be a
little
loose here and say that if you want to
do it on the whole
genome it will be have a few billion
base pairs
and so if you run the classical dynamic
programming algorithm that will take you
a little bit too long
so all right and again i i really want
to know why isn't there a linear time
algorithm why can't we even do enter the
1.99
and this is more than just a product
practical motivation it's sort of an
intellectual
question why
it would be nice to know okay so besides
so this was geometry and string matching
and now
for graph problems we also have such
examples so
here's a one of the simplest graph
parameters
and the diameter is the long largest
distance in the graph
and suppose i even give you a very
sparse graph you have n nodes in order n
edges and i want you to compute the
diameter
and maybe even i tell you approximate
the diameter give me an approximation
how fast can you do it the simplest
algorithm
is to compute all the pairwise distances
and find the maximum one but this will
inherently give a require n square time
because there's n squared pairs
uh and unfortunately we don't have a
significantly faster algorithm than that
so even even just approximating a
diameter better than
like a three-house approximation seems
to require and square time
and i will discuss this in a later talk
uh it has
actually being able to solve the
diameter faster implies things for
satisfiability and many other problems
so
okay so we have a lot of these examples
in just
just three areas of computer science but
there's many other areas where
such problems pop up and we would like
to know what's going on
so i'm not so n squared is not anything
special you could
say things about other runtimes so for
example
there's no end to the 1.5 minus epsilon
time algorithms for
problems in dense graphs so here n is
the number of nodes
squared so we have
n cubed little one cubed time algorithms
which translates to big
n to the 1.5 again is the input size
and so things like all pairs shorter
spells diameter radius median
lots of shortest paths related problems
in dense graphs
don't seem to have faster than and to
the 1.5
algorithms and so
again we have this issue we have some
class of problems a lot of problems
for which there's a polynomial time
algorithm that's basically the simplest
one you could come up with
and we don't know how to beat it okay
good i always talk for the same reason
so this is uh
one question are all problems that we're
stuck on
um difficult because of the same reason
is it because
we don't have the techniques to is one
big technique just going to solve all of
them
and how would we address this so in
order
in order to address it let's just go
take a step back and think about what
how we addressed it for the hard
problems
and here's a canonical heart problem
it's ksat
you have n variables and m clauses and
every clause is of the form
an or of k literals where each literal
is a
variable or its negation and you want to
know if there's some boolean assignments
to the variables
that makes this formula true so
there's a trivial two to the n algorithm
of times polynomial
of for this problem you try all possible
two to the end assignments
plug them in and check if the formula is
satisfiable now
if k is a constant you can actually do a
little better so you can do
t to the n minus some other constant
times n
over k times polyen time and
unfortunately as k grows this becomes
essentially 2 to the n
okay so the best known algorithm for cnf
sat in general is runs in roughly 2 to
the end time
and but this is not really why
uh the reason we give for why case that
is hard we
the reason we give is well k sad is np
complete
and this is why we think it's hard now
what does that really entail
it just says we believe it's hard
because
if it had a really fast algorithm let's
say party and time
then all problems in np have such an
algorithm
so the reason why we think ksat is hard
is because it is so expressive
it it captures all problems in mp
so uh
all right so we want something like this
for these easy problems we want to say
the reason why we think they're hard is
because
well they capture a lot of other
problems the hardness for a lot of other
problems okay okay
and the way we did this for the heart
problems is we use
polythene reductions now if we wanted to
do something like this for the easy
problems we can't
do this exactly so we have to be a
little bit more careful about
the runtime of our reductions so
i will tell you a little bit about that
in a moment
okay so here here's one approach you
could try
so the first thing we do is we're going
to identify
some key hard problems things we really
really believe
are hard things that we believe that we
cannot improve on their classical
algorithm
or brute force out there okay and then
what we'll do
we'll try to reduce these problems to
all all other possible hopefully all
other
hard easy problems okay it's a little
vague but i'll get into it
and then hopefully we'll sort of form
equivalence classes
and if we believe that all the problems
in which we're stuck on we're stuck on
for the same reason then we should
really have only one equivalence class
or
something like that but that's not where
we're at right now
and in the end one of
the major goals is sort of understand
what polynomial time looks like
so so far we've had some success in
understanding it so we had some
circuit classes and so on but i really
want to understand in terms of running
time so i want to know where things lie
okay so let's get into it so first i'm
going to tell you
the key heart problems we've looked at
and then
i'll talk about what the reductions look
like
and maybe i'll mention a little bit
about equivalence classes and so on
okay what are the hard problems uh
let's start with cnf set so we said okay
it's np
complete but actually it's going to
conjecture to be really really hard
and there's two popular conjectures
about set
the first one is that three set requires
exponential time
so t to the delta n time for some
constant delta
and the other even stronger conjecture
is that
for every epsilon there's some constant
k
such that k sat on n variables and m
clauses
cannot be solved in 2 to the n minus
epsilon n time
so if you uh
set epsilon to go to 0 essentially
k k sat for some ko can be solved into
the enzyme
okay so storing a th and eth
so one thing we could do is we could try
to take k sat for growing k
reduce it with some fancy reduction to a
bunch of problems
and say well we believe these problems
are difficult to improve
on the classical solution because
if we did that then this conjecture that
a lot of people seem to believe would be
false
now some people don't believe this
conjecture
but then you could say well these
reductions are ways to attack it
you know we're reducing them to easy
problems so you should be solving the
easy problems to
refute the conjecture so there's two
ways to look at it
okay so this is one of the hard problems
we looked at
here's three others
it's not hard okay there's three more
problems you can play
so here's a problem called threesome
it's been studied to death
basically so uh here you're given a set
of n integers and you want to know if
three of the integers in the set sum to
zero
i'll just define the problems and now
i'm going to there's a
second one it's orthogonal vectors now
this one you're given
n vectors in small over a small
dimension
d it's logarithmic let's say and you
want to know if two of these vectors are
orthogonal
now these the vectors themselves
have values zero and one so really what
we're asking is
are there two vectors or so whenever one
of them is one the other one is zero
so i just want to point out it seems
like a not too difficult problem
but uh it's kind of hard
okay and the third one
uh we're given a weighted graph you want
to find all the
distances so this is all pair shortest
path
i think everyone knows it okay so now
what
i'll do is i'll go through each of these
problems i'll tell you a little bit
about the prior work
and then i'll give you i'll tell you a
little bit about what we've been able to
show
okay so threesome again n integers you
want to some
check whether three of them sum to zero
uh
there's an easy and square time
algorithm um
easy and n squared log n is actually
very easy what you do is you take every
pair of integers in the set and check
whether the negative is also in the set
and you can shave off that another log
so
uh then in 2005 for andy maine and
patrasco
showed that you can actually shave two
more log factors
and whenever the set of numbers are
integers you can get an n squared over
log squared
n time algorithm now
if the set of numbers are real numbers
then even more recent results show that
even in that case you can do a little
bit better than n squared time
and get n squared over log n okay so
really n squared is not the right answer
but
um the real ones are um so this one is
in the word ram this one is in the real
wrap
and um yeah so the model matters here
okay so here from now on i'll talk about
threesome over the integers
uh this allows us to do some other
tricks like hashing and so on okay
and there's a folklore
result that says that if we're over the
integers we can just reduce the general
case to the case when the integers are
between minus and cubed and then cubed
and then there's this conjecture that
has been formulated in many many papers
which says
the three sum on a set of n integers
that lie in this range requires n
squared minus little wall of one time
so this is the very famous conjecture it
has been used to show that many many
problems
probably requiring square time there was
a term
that's used n squared hard which is very
strange but in computational geometry
they use it to mean
that you can reduce threesome to your
problem of interest
so there's a huge body of literature
that people where people have
explored using this conjecture as a
basis
for hardness excuse me yeah can you help
me it's about this foreclosure result
which is the idea
you can do a randomized reduction sort
of you can pick
a okay pick a random prime and so on for
example you could do that
i'll let you know okay there's a few
ways to do it
okay uh all right so there's three sum
and then orthogonal vectors
with orthogonal vectors again you have
and
n vectors over small dimension and you
want to know if two of them
are orthogonal there's an easy n squared
log n times solution
you try all pairs of vectors compute
their inner product and you check if
it's zero
now the best known algorithm okay that's
a little difficult to read
but what you should notice is when the
dimension is some constant times log n
you get a little bit of an improvement
depending on the constant in front of
the log so
it's always better than quadratic for
every constant
but as the constant goes to infinity it
goes to quadratic time
so this is a very recent result hence
the best known result for the problem
unfortunately even that result uses very
very sophisticated machinery
and it was still not enough to improve
on the
quadratic runtime substantially
so then there's this conjecture that
again has been formulated over and
over which says that this problem also
requires
n to the two minus little one time again
we can we have to specify the model
and so on don't you mean for the set of
d equal
uh where sorry
in the statement of the process oh yeah
um
for the actual conjecture you need a
little omega
yeah yes exactly
thank you so for the conjecture i have
to change the
problem so you can think of d as log
squared then i just i will just try to
save some space
okay so all right so
let's say the dimension is log squared
then that'll be fine
thanks
now there's this result from 2004 by
ryan and he showed that
if you believe the strong exponential
time hypothesis then you should also
believe this orthogonal vectors
conjecture
because he reduced k sat for okay
to uh this orthogonal vectors problem
and if you could improve an n squared
times substantially then you would also
improve on two to the n substantial
so i will actually prove this to you in
a little bit
so hang on okay
so this is that one and the final the
third problem is all pair shortest paths
so it's a classical problem has very
very very long history here's a little
slice of the history
so before 1976 it wasn't known whether
and cubed
thank you run time can be improved and
cubed you can get
by doing floor the floyd warshall
algorithm for example
and then fredman notice you can actually
improve it
on it a little bit you get a log to the
1 cubed
and 1 over 3n improvement and so on
and this was more and more log factors
were shaved up until
2012 and then ryan used some
very different machinery here to improve
on all
log factors so now you can get a 2 to
the square
log n improvement over n cubed
unfortunately this is still not a
polynomial improvement so we don't know
whether there is a better than n
into the three minus epsilon time
algorithm for any epsilon
and then there's this uh conjecture
that all pairs show the spells whenever
the integers are
on order log n bits it requires n cubed
minus little one time and all of these
conjectures
are about the word ram just just so
we're clear
so now now we've identified some key
problems and you can add more and more
to the list
and now what we want to do is take these
problems that we really really believe
are difficult because people from a lot
of uh
sub areas of computer science have tried
to solve them and
haven't succeeded so far and we want to
reduce them to
our favorite problems the diameter
problem to
let's say longest common subsequence
edit distance whatever you want
any any favorite problem that you have
we want to reduce one of these to them
okay but how how do we do these
reductions
um so we
coined this term fine grain reduction
which
is in line with the title of this
program okay so let's start with two
problems a and b
let's say they have some natural
algorithms and the algorithm for problem
a
runs in little of a time
and the algorithm from problem b runs a
little b event time
and now we say that a is reducible to b
in this if we can if we're improving on
the
this natural algorithm for b in a
substantial way
also implies that you beat this uh the
natural algorithm for a
uh this time so here's some way to do it
which i think is a natural way
so what you do is you take an instance
of a problem a
in order to reduce it to problem b you
you have a reduction which is an
algorithm that runs a little a
of n to the one minus delta time delta
some constant
as close to zero as possible and someone
because someone gives you
an epsilon for every epsilon give a
delta okay
and then you produce instances of b it
doesn't have to be one instance you can
have as many instances
as you want but the sizes of these
instances obey
this inequality here what does this
inequality say
it says that let's take the sizes of
these instances here to be
n1 and 2 and 3 and so on and then
when you run an algorithm of runtime b
of n1
and b of n2 and b of n whatever and
if you improve on the event by a
polynomial
you know by a constant factor in the
exponent
so then the total runtime of the
algorithm will be
the sum of b of n1 to the 1 minus
epsilon b of n2 to the 1 minus epsilon
and so on
plus the runtime of the reduction which
is a of n to the 1 minus delta and when
you
sum up these two up you get that you get
an algorithm for a
of the runtime a of n to the 1 minus
delta
so all i'm saying is that if you get
an improvement for problem b
with an epsilon improvement in the
exponent
then this translates into a delta in the
exponent improvement for problem a
okay so we're not actually saying that
the runtimes are preserved
so this is this is the important part
the runtimes are not necessarily
preserved
but what you do preserve is
the existence of a substantial
improvement
over the classical run time the natural
runtime so sometimes
usually this natural algorithm is some
brute force algorithm but sometimes it's
a dynamic programming algorithm and so
on
okay and the the thing is we focus on
the exponents because
when we talk when a and b are
polynomials then
this is improving over the the
polynomial
you know if it's n cubed improving on n
cubed if it's n squared improving on n
squared and so on
and using such a reduction we can form
these equivalences that talk about
improving over exhaustive search or
improving over
the natural runtime of problems
all right
yes why are we focusing on the naive
runtimes i mean
well i'm a little vague here so we can
for a lot of problems we do have
some natural way to solve them in a
brute force way for example think about
multiplying two matrices the brute force
way is you follow the definition you get
an n cube time runtime
okay so for some problems it's not as
natural so think about shortest paths
um yeah just going through all possible
paths that's too long but there is a
very natural
algorithm that doesn't go through a
possible past but
it's in a clever way it actually goes
through the optimal paths
so this is also a natural algorithm so
this is why i'm
being a little vague but it turns out
that often
these natural algorithms hide the brute
force algorithm
in them for maybe a simpler problem and
there's some
exhaustive search going on uh so
do you allow adaptive reductions oh yeah
here i'm not i haven't done that but yes
yeah you can you can do this
the way it's written it doesn't
but i mean you could you could get the
same properties allowing it out to
production
oh it doesn't rule out that oh it
doesn't oh okay just the way the picture
looks it looks like a non-attempted
yeah you can you can you can do this one
first then you can change the order
yeah yeah yeah it's it wasn't clear
whether you needed the answers you
actually needed the other reductions for
these according to
or yeah for yeah we'll you'll see
tomorrow
we have adapter actually it's important
yeah
it's not we don't always need them but
sometimes actually it's important to
have
yeah so you can the way you get this
reduction you may be the
how you pick this one depends on this
one and so on
so it is a little adaptive but this is
the basic idea
okay
so we're trying to build some theory of
hardness for polynomial time but also we
also
want to relate problems
uh maybe outside of polynomial time to
problems in polynomial time and in
general we're trying to
relate problems uh to each other
depending on
what we believe is a true run time
okay so here's again what we were
talking about
so i talked about the key heart problems
the reductions and now i'll discuss a
little bit about the equivalence classes
so okay there's a little map of some of
the things we know
so i'm going to try to go through it a
little bit so
so here's three the threesome problem
again and integers you want to check if
three of them sum to zero
in the 90s there was a huge uh
burst like a like a golden age of this
uh approach where you take threesome
reduce it to your favorite problem in
computational geometry that seems to
require
n squared time and then say well we
believe
that n squared time is the real answer
because we really don't think we can
improve and treat some substantial
so there was a really really huge body
of literature here
and it was confined to computational
geometry
okay and then recently we've been
taking threesome and also reducing it to
problems outside of computational
geometry
there's also a jump in
in the way reductions work uh in
the recent literature we've been
using some more so some hashing
techniques and things like this that
actually manipulate the integers in
question
in the previous work this wasn't done so
it would even
work the reductions would often even
work even assuming
that threesomes for real numbers
requires n squared types so maybe some
of these
are stronger but these use
more interesting techniques and you can
prove more and more results
okay so and this is really a growing
body of literature
now au pair shortest path
different problems we know how to reduce
cell pressures past two
for example the following problems in
dense graphs
radius so the radius is just like the
diameter except
now for every node you take the largest
distance from it and you take the node
that minimizes that
so a node that achieves the radius is
sort of a central node in the graph
so for indense graphs the radius problem
is actually equivalent to a pressure
disperse
median betweenness negative triangle
which are defined
second shortest path so what second
shortest path you're given
a graph we know how to compute the
shortest path between two nodes s and t
but now i tell you besides the shortest
path compute
the second shortest path the path the
second in the list
and we make the restriction it has to be
simple because
i don't know and now if we do that all
of a sudden
instead of taking linear linear time it
starts taking
n cube time and it turns out this is
because it's
equivalent to a pair shortest path so
these these two problems and many more
ryan and i
had a paper in 2010 that showed these
reductions that
followed in in the way uh that i had on
the slide
and what they say the equivalence is
that if you
get an end to the three minus epsilon
algorithm for any of these problems
then you get an n to the three minus
delta algorithm maybe
a different delta for all the others
so okay so we have all these problems in
uh in graphs that seem to be equivalent
to all pairs sure this path
yes all of these are on graphs of is
there a similar development for digraphs
oh yes yes yes by graphs i mean directed
graphs and interact
in fact in fact these problems uh
yeah even on in in both directed and
directed they seem to be equivalent
um right so we have
this growing body of equivalences
note that for threesome there's no
equivalence this is just one direction
there's very few problems that are known
to be actually equivalent to threesome
orthogonal vectors the problem where
you're given two
you're given n vectors you want to know
if two of them are orthogonal
we have reductions from that problem to
a bunch of problems is sparse graphs
and a bunch of problems in string
matching or sequence alignment and so on
so for example if you have uh
an n to the two minus epsilon prime
algorithm for any of these problems
uh long as common subsequence edit
distance
for shade instance
and diameter and so on then
orthogonal vectors also has a sub
quadratic time algorithm so
so we have orthogonal if you believe
that orthogonal vectors is hard
then a lot of problems in different
parts of
different parts of computer science
would have would also be
quadratic heart or whatever they will
require n squared time essentially
so again there's a very few equivalences
maybe one or two
between this problem and others but it
implies
hardness for many
now it turns out if you look at dynamic
graph problems so here
so what's the dynamic problem usually
what we do is
we want to compute some function but now
someone tells you this bit of the input
changed or
if you have a graph an edge disappeared
or an edge appeared
and now you want to update the function
okay
so that's a dynamic problem the question
there is
how fast can the updates be done
while being able to support queries
about the value of the function
so think about let's say i have a
directed graph and i want to maintain
the strongly connected components or
their number and now someone says this
edge
edge is no longer there now
you want to know that the number of
strongly connected components change
and what is that number so
it turns out that every one of these
problems can be reduced to some
subset of dynamic problems and some
dynamic problems can solve all these
three problems
so you can explain
the hardness of many dynamic problems by
focusing just on these three
core problems
okay as i mentioned i can take k sat for
growing k
so c and f set if you say and reduce it
to orthogonal vectors which means that
any of these problems and the ones here
would be if you get a substantially
improved algorithm for them
then the strong exponential time
hypothesis would be false
so so i'll show you this in a second
so this is uh most of what we know
there's a few other things that i'll
mention later but are there any
questions here
yeah the approach we're kind of doing
here
isn't like trying to create like some
quadratic complete problem it's more
like
maybe uh reduce like strong exponential
time hypothesis to one of these and then
reduce them to other things too well
okay so ideally i would like to say that
all these problems are equivalent
okay okay that's ideally what i want to
say sometimes
we don't know how to do it so then we
only get reductions and some
but we're getting proving some
relationships about problems
um and sometimes actually what you can
do is you can
build just as i'll show you in a second
the relationships will be
for different runtimes so it's uh
but so far um so
like ryan used a few days ago used the
the distinction between like classical
complexity
tends to be machine based you organize
problems by machine model
and this seems fine grain complexity
seems to be a problem-centered
approach exactly yes this is
problem-solving
exactly thanks
so what i'll do now is i'll present
ryan's reduction from 2004
and after you understand this reduction
then we can often just forget about
uh cnf set and just focus on orthogonal
vectors
uh it's not always the case sometimes
you can get reductions
that are not from orthogonal you can't
get a reduction from orthogonal vectors
but you can
from cns at or from you know with
constant
clause with but uh but most of the
reductions follow from this
okay so what are we going to prove we're
going to take
some for any k we take a k c and f
it will have n variables and order and
clauses we can assume this by the
specification lemma
and there should be enough here uh
i don't know why it's cutting off but
okay so
and then we will do we'll convert it to
an instance of orthogonal vectors so
that
if you can solve orthogonal vectors in
less than n squared time
then the original formula can be solved
faster than two to the end
okay so what we do is we take the
variables we split them arbitrarily into
two sets
of n over two variables each
then for every partial assignment
of v1 and v2 we're going to create
a vector if
we'll call the vector v
1 5 this j corresponds to
whether it's v1 or v2 and phi
is the partial assignment okay
now what we'll do is we'll forget about
this for a second
this part over here will just be we'll
have a coordinate for every clause
and uh for clause j we'll put a zero
if the partial assignment actually
satisfies this clause
and we'll put one otherwise now this
portion over here
it would just sort of say which part
which partial assignment to v1 or to v2
are we talking about if it's 2v1 we'll
put a 0
1 and if it's 2v2 we'll put a 1
0. so this basically means that if we're
talking about two partial assignments
two variables two
only v1 or to only v2 then the two
vectors will not be orthogonal because
they'll both have a one in this position
or both have a one in this position so
any two
any two vectors that are orthogonal
actually will be
will correspond to partial assignment of
the first half of the variables and the
partial assignment of the second half
okay and then once we have that
so in similarly to the second
to the partial assignments of the
variables of v2 we'll put a zero
if the partial assignment satisfies the
clause and
one otherwise now we look at two vectors
of this form
and we can see that the only way for
them to be orthogonal
is whenever this one has a one this one
has to have a zero so this means that
whenever
this partial assignment does not satisfy
this clause
this one has to satisfy it
here it is again so uh the only way so
a partial assignment phi and the partial
assignment psi
this one to the first half of the
variables this one to the second half
form two vectors that are orthogonal if
and only if together the concatenation
of the two partial assignments
satisfy the the formula
okay so and this completes the reduction
yeah couldn't you have an
assignment which satisfies a clause
in the bottom one end in the top one
yes yeah and then both of them will be
zero and then it will contribute nothing
to the inner product oh yeah so that's
why i picked zero there
yeah so if both partial assignments
satisfy the clause
uh both of them will be zero in that
coordinate so it
won't contribute anything and if one of
them satisfies that
the other one doesn't he'll have a one
times zero and it will be okay
and the only time when when uh
their orthogonal is when there's some
coordinated which both of them are one
but that means that neither of them
satisfied so so that's the claim
now what's the size what is the
reduction size
the number of vectors we get is roughly
two to the n over two
is two times that the dimension
is basically the number of clauses plus
two which is order n by our
specification lemma and this
little one is now log of big n
because the number of vectors is 2 to
the n over 2
and so we get that if you can solve
the orthogonal vectors problem for this
instance
and big n to the 2 minus delta time
you get a better dentist an algorithm
for the original form
now when you when you actually do the
proof you have to
uh care because uh strong eth actually
says
for every epsilon there exists a case or
that whatever
such that the runtime is two to the one
minus epsilon n
times so you have to be a little bit
more careful how you how you do this but
this is essentially the proof so
okay so now uh this is a
split and list technique and
most reductions either use orthogonal
vectors now as their base case for
proving hardness from
from strong a th or if they don't do
that
then they take a an instance of kc and f
and apply techniques that's very similar
to this so maybe
you don't split the variables into two
sets meant you split them into three
sets and then you do the partial
assignments
but usually it's something like this
all right so we're back to this picture
now we know this portion over here
and what else i'm going to say now
these are kind of maybe we maybe we
think these are kind of believable
conjectures
so we can ask what other conjectures can
we make
so so here's another one that appears in
the literature
um it's a conjecture about boolean
matrix multiplication
so you're given two boolean matrices a
and b
and you want to compute their product
which is defined as an
or of ands
okay and you can compute
an the omega time where omega is the
matrix multiplication exponent over
let's say the
reals or integers or whatever
and but people are not satisfied with
these algorithms because
they're hugely impractical so they
say well we don't want this we want a
combinatorial algorithm
so what is a combinatorial it's unclear
it doesn't have a real definition but
apparently you know it when you see it
so
um actually there are algorithms that do
not use
the big algebraic framework that we have
that
obtain poly logarithmic improvements
over and cubed
and the best search algorithm actually
was recently
discovered by one of our grad students
watching you
and he got enqueued over log to the four
and
this was an improvement over many years
the original
four russians algorithm got n cubed over
log squared then
so then there's this conjecture that any
combinatorial algorithms
for bmm requires and cubed minus at all
one time so
it's kind of a conjecture in quotes
because we don't really know what
combinatorial is but
but it's essentially saying you're not
allowed to use subtraction
you're not allowed to yeah it has to be
sort of some data structure stuff
something that seems simple to implement
and so on so this this conjecture is
then used to prove a lot of lower bounds
for for dynamic
problems and data structure problems and
so on
so because so it's not because it
doesn't seem to be using the batch
nature of algebraic multi matrix
multiplication algorithms it
allows you to prove things about dynamic
things that
do things one at a time anyway it's a
little vague but but this is another
conjecture that people focus on
i'm more in favor of the first three
that i mentioned
so here's some consequences so
um a triangle if you believe the
boolean matrix multiplication conjecture
then you
you cannot find a triangle in a graph
faster than n cubed minus at all one
time
using a combinatorial algorithm so in
fact
uh finding a triangle and computing the
boolean matrix product the equivalent
under these combinatorial fine grade
reductions
the radius of an unweighted graph
requires the same time if you focus only
on combinatorial techniques and notice
that bfs and
things like this are combinatorial so
you can prove things like this for also
maintaining a bipartite matching
dynamically
without doing so the trivial update
time so whenever you remove a measure
add an
edge to a graph in order to check if the
graph still has a perfect matching
you find if there's an augmenting path
so that a linear time of daytime is
possible doing something
better would actually
would actually refute the boolean matrix
multiplication conjecture
and really what all these reductions are
saying is that
even if you forget about combinatorial
that means that if
improving on the runtimes of these
algorithms actually
requires the use of fast matrix
multiplication so that's
that's what this is really saying
whenever you get yeah
so can you replace this reminder
it's a good question so the does this
imply that
boolean matrix multiplica so if we get a
into the
omega minus epsilon doesn't imply and to
the omega minus epsilon there and no
i mean uh sometimes we have a
substantial loss and you'll see this
tomorrow so when you say
combinatorial argument you you need some
model of computation so
for this to make sense what's the model
of computation
how do you get semantics out of this um
okay so suppose i even give you the word
ram i didn't i don't even know what
combinatorial means but usually what
these reductions do is they partition
the input in some clever way
they do some very simple things
everybody agrees are combinatorials
yeah essentially there's no formal model
and it's a big weakness of this thing
but it's hard to agree on anything
so we can talk about this offline but
it's
difficult
i guess and where grand hour is
developed
yeah you can you always the moment
someone builds it
you break it and yeah it's difficult
it's unclear like it was i was talking
to ryan people earlier because like
suppose they have uh
something that works over gf2 and it's
just zeros and ones how are you
excluding algorithm like for example
even strassen over gf2 but
isn't that combinatorial i mean i don't
know
so it's difficult to agree on the model
okay so all right
but again if you we have a very simple
reduction to problem
to from boolean matrix multiplication to
problems
that roughly preserves the learning
times then you also you say basically
these problems require fast
matrix multiplication techniques to
improve on the trivial algorithm
so another more complicated problem
is conscious free grammar parsing and so
on so i'm going to
talk about for two or three minutes
about this and then i'll be done
so which conjecture should we believe
um well there's no other reductions
between the conjectures that we know of
uh besides ryan's proof it could be that
one of them is true and all the others
are false or maybe
you know any subset of them could be
true while the others are false
as far as we know so
there's a few things you can say so you
can look at other models of computation
you can say well
if you look at the decision tree
complexities then actually there's uh
improved algorithms for three sum and
all pairs shortest
paths so they have much slower things
decision tree complexities than you
believe we don't really know this for
orthogonal vectors so maybe we should
think orthogonal vectors is the most
believable conjecture
sort of a vague intuition now orthogonal
vectors and
whole pair shortest paths admit these
wonderful algorithms that beat all
logarithmic speedups
but we don't know how to do this for
threesome so maybe
threesome is hard harder than the other
two
uh we don't know how to discuss this but
what we do know
is that there are natural problems that
all these three
threesome all pictures pass and and cnf
said
all reduced to and uh we had a paper
about this so these are very simple
problems about
the triangles in a graph and there's no
numbers in the graph so it's just an
unweighted problem
we do have colors so what is this
problem triangle collection
you have a graph on the nodes every node
has a color
so okay maybe it's ordering colors and
now
i want to know if the set of triangles
hits all triples of colors so what does
this mean
does every triple of colors blue green
red
you restrict your graph on on these
colors
the whenever you do that is there a
triangle
that has all these three colors as its
nodes
so the triangle collection as is there
a triangle in every triple of colors
and then there's something again
matching triangles here you're given
again a graph with colors on the nose
and you want and a number delta
and you want to know is there a triple
of colors that has at least delta
triangles
if delta is one then is there
this is equivalent to is there a
triangle in the graph as delta goes to
log n
this becomes hard so it turns out that
you can reduce
threesome all pressures past nk sat
to both these problems and if you can
implode it can improve substantially
over n cubed on either of these
then all three sum has a sub quadratic
algorithm all patients past has a sub
cubic algorithm
and c and f sat and stronger th is false
so
yeah this is these are the problems you
should solve if you do not believe these
conjectures
so we can add these here let's say i add
triangle collection we can reduce
case at el paso pass and threesome to
them also it turns out
that you can reduce triangle collection
to problems uh
very interesting problems for example
maintaining
let's say i want to maintain the number
of strongly connected components of a
graph
under edge insertions and deletions if
your
update time is sublinear
then then triangle collection has a
subcubic algorithm
which means that all of our conjectures
are false
so which is actually strictly means that
that problem is strictly harder so
it's sufficient that one of these
conjectures is true for
us to believe that dynamic strongly
connected components is a difficult
problem
so okay and there's some other problems
related to max flow that has
they have similar hardness
okay so i'll talk about this tomorrow
that on thursday and of dynamic problems
on friday
okay that's it thanks
one question going back to the very
beginning when you're beginning with a
problem
i was trying to figure out if the square
in the as a parameter
has anything to do with the dimension of
the setting like k longest common
subsequence
geometry problems
oh i see yes yes so the question is can
we go to enter the k
instead of n squared by uh having a
parameter k in the problem
and sometimes you can do uh for longest
common
subsequence klcs seem to require
whatever
into the k time and k dominating set
seems required to the case so you can do
this for some problems for other
problems is not as trivial
so for example for diameter how do you
have to completely change the problem so
there are natural parametrizations of
these problems that
lead to this
i'm curious are there and the many
problems where
you've reduced two of those three to the
problem but not all three
yes so the question is are there any
problems for which you can reduce
two of the problems on on the picture to
them but not all three of them and yes
so there's this problem
uh called exact weight triangle so here
you're given a graph
on n nodes and you have weights on the
edges you want to know if there is a
triangle in a graph so
three click where the weights sum to
zero you can reduce all pairs shortest
paths and threesome to this problem
so that it's truly sub cubic algorithm
for that one implies truly sub quadratic
for threesome and truly sub cubic for
all pair shirt is passed but we do not
know how to reduce
uh cnfsat or orthogonal vectors to
yeah are it any lower bounds and there
are some restricted models for
any of those problems uh yes so are
there lower bounds in restricted models
for these problems
yes there are there is a
and square lower bound for threesome for
um when you're allowed to compare linear
combinations of the of the
sums of the numbers and then you can
compare those uh then you require and
square time
for uh all pay shortest paths there is
an n cube lower bound under similar
model
and there are some things like this can
i capture the current best algorithm
um because you can get
more than power logarithmic improvements
are these but
there's an actually n cubed and n
squared for this
so is there any evidence you can't
reduce sat to say threesome like you did
for orthogonal vectors
yes um yes i'll tell you about this
maybe if you the reason worked with
mohamed baturi and ours are our poor
students who are in the audience
somewhere marcos there and
others are scattered so if you believe
that
a non-deterministic version of the
strong strong exponential time
hypothesis
then from that it follows that you
cannot reduce
orthogonal vector to just say threesome
or all their shorts
maybe one of the students will talk
about this soon
there seemed to be a reduction in
introduction to
uh orthogonal vectors you could go to
three
you won't see yourself there mutually
orthogonal yes
and is that interesting does that give
me anything uh yes
yes so the question is instead of just
doing two orthogonal vectors you could
reduce
uh sat in the same way to getting
three mutually orthogonal vectors or
four and so on and yes
you can you can get reductions from
problems like this to some problems
yeah uh but yeah
yes you can do that i think these
problems though
maybe they're easier
so we have this conjecture of this
online boolean
matrix multiplication so there you can
get rid of the combinatorial
thing at the cost of assuming that
online boolean matrix multiplication
what does that mean
so you have a matrix that's fixed and
then a sequence of vectors comes
and whenever a vector come you have to
multiply the vector with a matrix so
it's not matrix matrix multiplication
but it's vector matrix multiplication
and it's online but then you don't need
the term combinatorial
but the disadvantage of this of this
conjecture is of course that people have
not thought about this online
version and so maybe there is a fast
algorithm we don't know yet
but i just wanted to mention this the
other you can get rid of the term
combinatorial and then we can show that
various dynamic problems are hard
if you assume this online matrix vector
but for static problems though yeah it's
unclear
for dynamic problems it's extremely
useful but for static essentially
but i mean i actually encourage the
community to maybe come up with the past
algorithm show that this online
matrix vector assumption is wrong just
one of these conjectures where
even fewer people have worked thanks
monica
i do have more another talk about this
thanks yeah
it was just that point that i know
graham at all in the 70s have been
online
with context through grammar but it's
actually similar it's exactly
it's exactly the same you can apply to
boolean matrix multiplication so
and then i know ryan um his method
the log log log squared is also online
yeah so ryan had a paper on doing
orthogonal
so if you you can pre-process boolean
matrix multiplication and then
you can feed it vectors to multiply with
and then he can get
uh n squared over log squared runtime
for this
and there uh monica and else conjecture
is now that actually no matter how much
preprocessing you you throw
at it as long as it's polynomial then uh
the vectors the
the matrix vector multiplications
require n to the two minus little of one
time
so maybe you can save n to the little of
one factors but you're not going to get
into the 1.9
so
thanks again
you